no and it was always about the terms and
it's it's stupid to say that this was
our plan to get subscribers I'm sorry
like I get a little bit pissed off with
this because that means that you didn't
pay any attention at all to mug Club
forever that was us getting in touch
with our subscribers and making sure
that whatever home we went to on our own
with somebody else we were going to have
access to the people that paid for our
content this was not a plan that was
hatched to make sure that we could write
off into freedom and do whatever the
hell we wanted with this really great
email list it would be it would be the
hardest waiting for that we said it yeah
it was clear and you saw the numbers
there it sounds like you guys are like
right on the precipice of creating your
own network or your own website where
people pay you 10 bucks a month and just
get access I really don't want to have
to do that like here's the thing right
wouldn't you wouldn't it be great if you
could link arms with the self-professed
most powerful people on our side were
supposedly fighting for us but the
problem is when they say we have no
interest in doing that you go wait hold
on hold on a second here's the good news
I bring Tidings with great joy we can
get just as many viewers on Rumble as
you can on YouTube